- Thanks to Trade Coffee for keeping
"Legal Eagle" in the air,
'cause you would not want to see me
before my first cup of joe, am I right?
Ugh, all right, let's
watch "Tiger King" again.
- [Lawyer] Where's the film?
- [Joe] In my recording studio.
- [Lawyer] And they don't
have copies of it or anything?
- [Joe] No.
- [Lawyer] Do you see
what I'm saying, Joe?
- [Joe] I hear you.
- Don't record your lawyer.
Do not record your lawyer
without permission.
I cannot emphasize that highly enough.
(lighthearted music)
Hey all you cats and kittens,
I mean legal eagles. (beeps)
I told you, this one almost broke me
but you guys had a lot
of unanswered questions.
Just when I thought I was
out, you pull me back in.
But I wanted to cover
some of the other things
that I left out in the original
"Real Lawyer Reacts to Tiger King,"
some of the other crimes committed
allegedly, allegedly, in the documentary,
and some of the other
crimes that the characters
definitely committed offscreen.
Look, if Joel McHale can squeeze out
an eighth episode of "Tiger King"
with an iPhone and AirPods
in his ears the whole time,
we can do a second episode
of "Real Lawyer Reacts."
So without further ado,
let's dig in to "Tiger King"
again for some reason.
- The last day that I saw Don,
he told me that he was done,
that he was divorcing her,
that she was one of the worst people
he'd ever met in his life,
and she was very dangerous.
- He indicated to me that he was
going to tell Carole
that he wanted a divorce.
Never saw him again.
- Okay, so right off the bat,
probably the biggest question I got was
did I think that Carole
Baskin committed murder?
On this channel, I tend to avoid
trying to make judgment calls like these
when not all of the facts are known.
Sometimes I will go out on a limb
and I will give my opinion as to whether
I think a crime was committed
or whether a lawsuit
is meritorious or not,
but almost always that's in
cases where most of the facts,
if not all of the facts, are known.
Like for example a copyright case
where I can look at the
allegedly infringing piece of art
and the original piece of art,
and I don't need to know
more facts than that.
And that's really all that's relevant
in a copyright case, for example.
But here, this is a one-sided
documentary with an agenda.
I don't know that anyone
can really opine on this.
I will say that in doing more research
for this episode and the prior episode,
there's a lot more information
about Don's medical diagnosis,
about his Alzheimer's
and his bipolar disorder.
There's a lot more in terms
of the conservatorship cases
between him and his former family.
So there are a lot of facts out there
that are not in the documentary
that I think are probably relevant here
that I think paint things
in a different light.
And the documentary needs to have
equal parties opposing each
other for narrative purposes.
You need to have a good guy and a bad guy
or a bad guy and another bad guy
of relatively equal power,
and that lends to the narrative.
So I would say if you're
interested in this,
check out Carole Baskin's
retort to the documentary.
She puts out a lot of
additional facts out there,
it's on the Big Cat Rescue's website,
and judge for yourself.
But I don't think it's my place
to opine on whether I think Carole Baskin
killed her former husband.
I will say, though, that
between Joe and Carole Baskin,
only one of those people
is in federal prison
with a potentially life
sentence to serve out.
So take that as you will
and you decide who deserves
the benefit of the doubt there.
- [Joe] My producers are
filming a reality show.
- [Lawyer] So they wanna do a show
related to your park up there?
- [Joe] They actually got it filmed.
- Do they?
- Uh-huh.
- [Lawyer] And how are
you protecting that?
- [Joe] What do you mean?
- [Lawyer] Well, if they've got it filmed,
what do they need you for?
- He blew up so bad when I
showed him that contract.
He was like, "You don't own me."
I said, "Joe, actually, I do right now.
"I do own this show, I do own it."
- [Lawyer] Where is the film?
- [Joe] In my recording studio.
- [Lawyer] And they don't
have copies up here?
- [Joe] No.
- [Lawyer] You see what I'm saying, Joe?
- [Joe] Yeah, I hear you.
- Don't record your lawyer.
Do not record your lawyer
without permission.
I cannot emphasize that highly enough.
There's really no reason for Joe
to have recorded this in the first place.
Number one, if you record it
and then you show it to somebody else,
you are waiving the
attorney-client privilege.
You are removing the
confidence of the discussion
between you and your attorney,
and therefore third parties can get access
to the things that you
discussed during that meeting.
On top of that, without permission,
if this is a one party consent state,
you might be violating
their right to privacy.
On top of that, you have evidence
that is bad for both of you
because if indeed the lawyer is suggesting
that you go out and commit a crime,
that might qualify as
conspiracy to commit arson.
Lawyers have an ethical obligation
to inform law enforcement when they know
that a crime is going to be committed,
so that goes beyond the realm
of attorney-client privilege
in the first place.
Now obviously we don't know
exactly what's going on here.
This footage, I think,
is pretty chopped up.
It's meant to imply that something
nefarious is going on
between Joe and his attorney,
so we don't know exactly
what was discussed.
But the implication is that the lawyer
is suggesting that he
go out and commit arson.
There's no attorney-client privilege
that's going to attach
when you actively suggest
to a client that they go
out and commit a crime.
There are very, very,
very big problems here.
- That building, where
the alligators were kept,
as well as a studio that Joe had,
it was clearly an arson,
it was a set fire.
- It had burned so hot,
there was nothing left.
I dropped to my knees and I cried.
- Okay, just as I am not going to opine
on whether I think Carole Baskin
killed her former husband,
I'm not going to opine on who I think
committed the arson here.
This is, I think, based on what
is shown in the documentary
clearly an act of arson.
It doesn't seem like there's any
natural reason why this
thing would catch fire.
And there are people with definite motives
as to why they might commit arson.
What I will say, though, is that
if one sets fire to their
own property intentionally,
that still qualifies as arson.
So you can't just go around
torching your own stuff
because obviously that can
create negative externalities
and you might catch your neighbor's
alligator enclosure on fire as well.
So we don't want all of
their stuff burning down too,
so if you set fire to your own barn,
that qualifies as arson, don't do that.
- So I'm Dr. Bhagavan Antle.
B-H-A-G-A-V-A-N Antle, A-N-T-L-E.
Dr. Bhagavan Antle.
- Okay, let's talk about Doc Antle.
There are two really interesting
things about Doc Antle.
Number one is that everyone was curious
about potential sexual harassment claims
based on the sort of implied
cult-like behavior at this institution.
- If they wanted to get
to the top really quickly,
they should sleep with him.
- In general, there are two
kinds of sexual harassment.
There's quid pro quo sexual harassment
and then there's hostile
workplace environment.
Quid pro quo is do
something of a sexual nature
for me and you'll either be rewarded
or you'll be punished
if you don't do this.
- He controlled every aspect of our day.
What we were allowed to do.
Definitely what we were
allowed to eat as vegetarians
but also they were pushing
me to get implants.
- And then the hostile work environment
is using the basis of sex to create
some hostile work environment.
And you can imagine that
if you are pressuring women
to have plastic surgery, that
could certainly give rise
to a hostile work environment
and give rise to a
sexual harassment claim.
Now the other really interesting
thing about Doc Antle
is that his compound in South Carolina
was raided by the police
in December of 2019.
Now, Antle claims that the warrants
had to do with tracing lions
that ended up in his institution
that came from a park of very ill repute,
and that the police were just simply
trying to track down information
related to somebody else.
The police are not saying why it is
that they raided his park.
As you can imagine, they are not likely
to comment on an ongoing investigation.
But it's sort of up to you as to
whether you think that it's related
to Doc Antle's own improper
conduct regarding animals,
or it's related to somebody else, or both.
But again, we don't
have all the facts here.
- [Lawyer] It doesn't show stalking,
it doesn't show battery.
It doesn't show anything.
It shows a verbal argument,
and that's not enough
to get an injunction.
- [Don] And so that's why
you think it was denied.
- That's why I know it was denied.
- [Don] But obviously--
- That was dead on arrival.
What raises my eyebrows is
she threatened to kill me.
- [Don] And that's not enough to get a--
- Nope.
- A restraining order?
- It's free speech.
There's free speech.
We don't restrain free
speech in this country,
we punish it after it's done.
- Got a lot of questions
about Don's attempt
to get a restraining order
and the attorney's comments
that it was just free speech,
so we punish speech after the fact
instead of getting restraining
orders ahead of time,
and that's, it's very half right.
It's maybe a quarter right.
Now, first of all, in Florida
you can get a domestic restraining order,
and it doesn't require an
actual act of physical abuse.
In Florida, a restraining order
is generally known as an
injunction for protection.
It's a civil court order,
but if you violate that order
that can lead to a criminal offense.
It does not require violence.
You can get it if there's
a history of abuse
or they're real, credible threats.
And generally speaking, there's a thing
under First Amendment
law called a true threat,
which is not protected
by the First Amendment.
So you can't go around
making true threats to people
and thinking that you're
going to escape liability.
So it is possible for Don
to get a restraining order
under these circumstances,
but you can imagine
where that is simply generalized threats,
it would be difficult.
Oh, and speaking of restraining orders,
Don wasn't the only one who wanted
to get a restraining order.
Joe's ex-husband, John
Finlay, has a history
of some criminal activity,
including in 2014 he was arrested
for domestic assault and battery
when he reportedly attacked Joe,
although he was never charged.
And months later, in October of 2014,
Finlay filed for a
protective order against Joe,
but that protective
order was also dismissed
because he failed to
meet his burden of proof.
And in September of 2018,
the mother of his young daughter
filed for a petition
for a protective order
against John Finlay himself.
So a lot of protective
orders going around,
a lot of potential assault and battery.
It's a really sad
situation, unfortunately.
- With Jeff Lowe coming in to help him
Joe believed that if he just convinced us
that he had endless resources
to keep the lawsuit going,
we would suddenly fold
our tent and go away,
which of course we were not going to do.
- [Joe] My lawyers recommended
that we just dissolve
the Garold Wayne Interactive Zoo company
and let Jeff open one in his name
so Carole would have to start
the lawsuits all over again.
- Ah, Jeff Lowe.
What can be said about Jeff Lowe?
I would've thought he
dressed really cool in 1997.
So initially when I saw
this potential investment
from Jeff Lowe into Joe's zoo,
it sounded like another
fraudulent transfer.
We talked about, in the prior episode,
about the fraudulent transfer
between Joe and his mother,
Shirley Schreibvogel,
which we know it was a fraudulent transfer
because she admitted as much.
He was trying to hide his assets
by putting them in the
name of somebody else,
which, don't do that.
So if you wanna hear all about
that fraudulent transfer,
check out "Real Lawyer Reacts
to Tiger King Part 01."
I'll put a link in the description.
But it sounded like Jeff Lowe
was doing the exact same thing.
He was taking title to the zoo
in an effort to prevent Carole Baskin
from getting the assets of the zoo.
It seems like he's done
more than that, though.
It sounds like he's made
a material investment
into the zoo itself.
I don't have all the facts here,
but it sounds like this
may be more bonafide
than the transfer to Joe's mother.
So I didn't think we can necessarily
say Jeff Lowe committed a
fraudulent transfer here.
And given that he's actively
running the zoo itself,
he had to make some sort of investment.
It's hard to do, but it's not impossible
to invest in distressed assets like this
without it being a fraudulent transfer.
- He decided he wants to stay in Vegas
and try and make money out there.
He talked a sponsor into buying a bus
and they called it the Jungle Bus.
- [Saff] Like a party bus with animals.
- Why?
- [Reinke] They haul people
from casino to casino
and let them play with cubs
while they're doing it.
- We thought it would be a
good idea, but we were wrong.
That was a big (beep) mistake.
- Huh, yeah, so even if we give
Jeff Lowe the benefit of the doubt
with respect to the G.W. Zoo,
I'm not sure we can give
him the benefit of the doubt
with respect to his Vegas business.
According to court
documents, Mr. Lowe faces
open court cases in Las
Vegas Municipal Court
where he's accused of doing business
without a license in 2017,
and failing to obtain a license or permit
for wild or farm animals.
So I can't imagine why adding big cats
to a shuttle service
for drunk Vegas tourists
wouldn't work out.
Seems like a really,
really bad investment.
But a good investment would be
to subscribe to this channel.
In fact, I was checking
my Google Analytics
and only 30% of the people
that watch this channel
are subscribed to this channel.
So please subscribe if
you like this content.
And if you click the notification bell,
I'm in the comments for the first hour
after I release a video.
So you can ask me all of the rest
of the crazy questions we
have about "Tiger King."
Ah, (beep) my life.
And it probably won't surprise
you to learn that Jeff Lowe
also has pleaded guilty
to mail and wire fraud.
- Saff, you identify as a man.
Were you upset when they kept
referring to you as she on the show?
- I don't think it bothered me
as much as it bothered everyone else.
I didn't really pay it any mind.
- Okay, let's talk about Saff.
Apparently in the original documentary,
the documentarians misgendered Saff.
I was using female pronouns
and apparently that's not correct,
so I apologize for that miscommunication.
I guess that was cleared
up in the eighth episode
which I hadn't seen by the time
that I did the first episode
of "Real Lawyer Reacts."
But regardless, Saff is
a pretty tough cookie
given that they were
able to get back to work
after getting their arm ripped off.
- Who would you trust first again:
Joe Exotic or the tiger
who bit your arm off?
- The tiger.
- Saff also has a bit
of a checkered history
including being arrested
at least eight times
by the Garvin County,
Oklahoma Sheriff's Department,
including charges for
DUI, carrying weapons,
obtaining goods with a false premise,
and failure to appear for warrants.
So yeah, tough cookie and a
checkered history as well.
- Well, Joe came to me one
day just out of the blue.
He says, "You think Allen
could kill somebody?"
I said, "Is he capable of it?"
And I said, "Of course, who's not?"
- I said, "I'll cut her (beep)
head of for you if you want."
And he was all into that.
I said, "Would you like
me to bring it back?"
"No, no, get rid of it in the swamp!"
I was like, "Okay, will do."
- Frank Allen Glover.
He seems like such a normal, nice guy.
A lot of people had
questions about his plea deal
and his prior history.
Allen Glover has been
arrested at least 20 times
including DUI, domestic violence,
possession of drugs,
and assault and battery.
Like you name it, this guy has
basically been accused of it.
So given this guy's past history,
they were surprised
that he was not charged
in the same conspiracy to
murder that Joe Exotic was.
And prosecutors and US
attorneys have a lot of leeway
in terms of who they will charge and why.
And coopering with the government
is a great way to get a
reduction in your sentence,
to get a reduction down
to suspended probation,
or sometimes not being
even charged at all.
Now it's a weird interplay between
the way that this works
in the federal system,
where there are sentencing
guidelines that,
try as you might, the
prosecutors have less leeway
in terms of being able to forgive people
based on their cooperation
with the government.
Now, the way that they
tend to get around that
is that instead of saying,
"You were charged with
conspiracy to commit murder,
"and we're only gonna give
you probation for that,"
that generally doesn't work
under the sentencing guidelines.
They simply only charge him
with a lesser included crime,
something that can be
pled down to no jail time
or some other suspended sentence.
So I suspect that is what happened here,
that they just simply didn't charge him
with the same crime that
Joe Exotic was charged with,
and they went for the maximum
penalty for Joe Exotic
because he was the sort of mastermind
and the one that they
really wanted to take down
based on the egregiousness
of his behavior.
- You forged my name 20
(beep) times on cashed checks.
Just in that 12 months,
while he was running
for the Governor of Oklahoma,
we found, I think, 88,000 some dollars
in misappropriated spending.
You just do whatever the (beep) you want
without even asking me, and it's wrong!
- It might surprise you to learn
that Joe's campaign for
Governor of Oklahoma
was not on the up and up.
Under Oklahoma law, you are not allowed
to use corporate funds to fund
an individual run for a political office.
So really, using the funds of the G.W. Zoo
for his ill-fated campaign for governor
is basically just embezzlement.
In Oklahoma, corporations are prohibited
from making contributions to candidates,
PACs, and party committees,
but they can make
unlimited contributions
to ballot measures.
If Joe in fact did use any
corporate funds of the G.W. Zoo
for his own political
campaign above limits,
definitely a campaign finance violation.
And speaking of Joe's run
for Governor of Oklahoma,
let's talk about his
campaign manager, Josh Dial.
- I was Joe's campaign manager
for about a year and a half.
It was the worst experience of my life.
It was horrible, horrible, horrible.
- Now although Josh was the
relative voice of reason
throughout this show,
he has a checkered past
including a 2017 felony
assault and battery.
The affidavit that was
sworn out against him
states that Dial, "Cut,
stabbed, or slashed,"
I presume his boyfriend,
"with a Japanese Ninja sword, a katana."
The victim had an 11 centimeter laceration
and the victim was sent to the hospital
via emergency air evacuation.
If only there had been a warning sign
that seemingly normal Josh Dial
might not be as
well-adjusted as we thought.
- I'm a Libertarian, so
technically (beep) the feds.
- All right, so let's tally up
all the crimes staring with Joe.
He was sentenced to 19 different counts.
His sentence included
108 months for each of
the two murder for hire
counts, totaling 216 months.
He got 12 months for each of the
Endangered Species Act violations,
and 14 months for the
Lacey's Act violations,
all to run concurrently.
Now regarding all of the other
characters in "Tiger King,"
there are just simply
too many crimes to count,
so I'm not even going to try it.
All right, let us never talk
about "Tiger King" again,
because I need a drink.
No, I need something stronger
than this, like Trade Coffee.
Trade is great because
not only do they have
a huge selection of your favorite coffees,
but they have an awesome
quiz to get matched
to the coffee recommendations
based on your taste preferences.
I don't actually drink coffee
every day, but when I do,
like when I have to force
myself to get through
eight hours of legal insanity
involving big cats and crazy people,
I want my coffee to actually taste good.
And with Trade, you can
discover new coffees
from the nation's top roasters.
Trade matches you with your own
personal selection of coffee
and conveniently delivers it to you.
And let's just say that you're watching
eight hours of "Tiger
King," hypothetically,
and that drove you to start drinking
at 10 o'clock in the morning.
Ah, (beep) my life.
Well, they could probably match
a coffee for that as well.
Now, the first 100 Legal Eagles will get
30% off their first bag when they sign up,
and you get free shipping.
Just click on the link in the description,
take the quiz, choose your frequency,
whether you want one
bag or a subscription,
and then rate your coffee
so your suggestions
get better over time.
And you can even choose whole
beans or your preferred grind.
It's really the best
coffee website out there.
So to get 30% off of your first order,
click on the link in the description
or use the promo code Legal30 at checkout.
Clicking on that link really
helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my
analysis of "Tiger King?"
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other
real lawyer reactions,
including my prior
reaction to "Tiger King"
of all the others things that
I didn't cover here today.
So click on this link and
I'll see you in court.